welcome to the final stretch we are less
than two months out from election day
and the race for the white house
continues to tighten and a lot
president trump making stops in florida
and north carolina while biden takes a
break from the campaign trail
a day after his event in pennsylvania
the president railing against joe biden
while in the sunshine state this
afternoon
my administration is proving every day
that we can
improve our environment while creating
millions of high-paying
jobs this is a really sharp contrast to
the extreme
radical left that you've had to deal
with joe biden's plan would destroy
america's middle class
the contrast between our vision and the
radical left has never been more clear
they talk a big game and they do nothing
let's face it joe's shot if joe biden
gets in
your second amendment is gone
and the battleground brawl is starting
to ramp up too with president trump
closing
the gap with biden on some coveted swing
states politico is noting that quote
while national polls have generated a
portrait of biden holding a commanding
lead it's something of a mirage
in the swing states that matter it is
trench warfare biden's advantage
according to the real
clear politics polling average is within
the margin of error
in half of the eight states and trump is
a president whose support has been
notoriously difficult
for pollsters to survey so juan i think
that i would like to go to you first and
just talk about the fact that we are two
months away where do you see the state
of the race at this time
well i tend to break it down pretty much
in binary terms dana you know who would
you rather be
as you start the sprint to the finish
line would you rather
be a guy who is having money trouble
at the moment and seems to have spent
money early on and now
is having to pull ads in key states like
michigan
or would you rather be someone who just
raised a record amount of money in the
month of august
would you rather be someone who's
dealing with allegedly making derogatory
statements about
you know our war dead or would you
rather be someone who sent his son to
battle
you know under the american flag so i
think that
if you look at it in those terms and you
look at the big poll numbers
as you say it's tight in some states but
even in the swing states the majority of
the swing states now favor biden and you
have a number of
states like arizona that previously
would have been thought to be in the
republican column that now look pretty
good
so it's you know you always have to give
the advantage to the incumbent
but i'd say right now you know as we
start the sprint as you put it dana i'd
rather be biden than trump
and the nbc marist poll today jesse it
showed
something i think the trump campaign
we're probably very happy with a tie at
48.48
and then an increase in support from
2016 to now
with hispanic voters from about 35 in
2016 to 50 percent
in uh 2020 so that's quite a significant
change and also
just the look and feel of the campaign
like the president's on the road
he's there he's at a beautiful stop
there in jupiter florida he's making big
announcements including one about you
know oil drilling off the coast
so when juan says you'd rather be biden
than trump at this point
i'm assuming you have a different point
of view well
juan says it's a sprint but joe's not
even moving
the president's in two swing states
today biden's in his basement doing
god's
knows what permission to make a sports
analogy dana
sure all right let's see how what you
got so biden's playing basketball
and he's just four corners he's just
trying to run out the clock
trump's full court press he's fast break
he's aggressive
biden's on the defense take a look at
the florida poll nbc they have it tied
it's unskewed
that's a poll that they actually have
the breakdown reflecting the 2016 exit
polls
and biden's losing hispanics trump's
doing much better with cubans and
venezuelans has a little bit more work
to do with puerto ricans
in the orlando area but the president
will win florida i can guarantee that
look at how he's doing in north carolina
over performing with blacks
his push for charter schools school
choice
is really paying off and now according
to east carolina
university he's up two points there if
i'm
joe biden i'm nervous because right now
donald trump is within the margin of
error in every single battleground state
you talk to the trump campaign they're
pretty confident i don't think the biden
campaign is that confident
if you want to look at numbers the
republicans are out registering
democrats by massive margins in florida
they're about registered and by
450 000 north carolina
230 000 pennsylvania a hundred and fifty
thousand
the president's approval rate in
rasmussen right now is at 51
democrats very nervous about that
because at this stage of the re-election
for barack obama and rasmussen he was at
48 percent got reelected
bush was at 51 percent erasmus at this
point
got reelected i think this race is dead
even with the president having a slight
edge
and right now i'd rather be president
trump
all right and greg obviously greg you
could talk about whatever you want but i
did want to
see if you had thought anything about um
these
you see these videos of joe biden doing
q a
with some people over zoom but
apparently possibly you know reading his
responses
from a teleprompter how dare he
read from a teleprompter
it's not so much the reading it's that
it just he looks like he's out of gas
even when he wakes up in the morning and
uh it is kind of like when you drive a
lemon off the lot
and it doesn't make it to the highway
that's how it kind of feels
but this is a we talked about the polls
and i think this is the toughest
election
in recent memory since 2016. to poll
because it's the first time the media
and the democrats
and pop culture in general has painted a
rather large
target on the back of a group of voters
than being trump voters which forces
them into the shadows
so when you talk about shy voters we're
only
under counting trump voters people are
only
lying that they're voting for joe they
aren't lying
voting for trump because why would you
vote why would you lie about something
that would get you
abused that would that's like going to
the doctor and telling him
that you're smoking more no no no no
when you're gonna lie to your doctor
you're gonna tell him that you've lost
weight
and that you're you you've cut your
smoking in half
so there's a really simple experiment
for the media to do go to a trump event
in a biden shirt then go to a binding
event in a trump shirt and
compare and contrast and see how people
treat you lastly to the derogatory story
in the atlantic i need to comment on
that
you need to have an anonymous story like
that
when there's an economic recovery a jobs
recovery and hopefully a strong path to
corral coven which i think is happening
so you need stuff like this
but the funniest thing about the
atlantic story and this upcoming michael
cohen book they're like a farmer's
almanac that tells you the weather that
already happened
right so wait a second you're telling me
that
trump says offensive things in public
oh my god what do we do we've only known
that for four years
maybe even longer than that and lastly
for the journalists out there let's come
up with a
real definition of what confirmation
means because confirmation
of an unproven allegation from a source
isn't a confirmation of fact it's a
confirmation of an unproven allegation
all right let me ask you about this
emily there's this other factor in north
carolina
where the polls are tightening perhaps
but i think republicans are a little bit
more stressed out about the fact
that when it comes to early voting and
absentee ballot requests
the democrats have astronomical
advantages on that point and early
voting
is already underway so you know we
obviously talk about whatever you want
but i do think that there is some making
up to do at least on that front
yes i agree with that dana and here's
what i wanted to focus on since i'm
going last today i wanted to be the
caveat
caller here on the panel because in
these battleground states
that will determine the election it is a
three-point race with only two months to
go
and we all remember in 2016 when trump
was behind in pennsylvania at this time
by two points behind by three points in
michigan
and seven points in wisconsin and
obviously he won
all three so i think the national media
is obviously focusing on national polls
and some state polls have suspect voter
polls
jesse the florida one that you were
mentioning on that was an interesting
skew toward republican
uh voter makeup and it only interviewed
138 hispanics so i think we should sort
of
take a step back and understand that
polls at this point are not going to
reflect necessarily the mood
and the preferences of the electorate
especially when we're waiting for
a covid stimulus coming out there's
obviously a lot of unrest
in urban environments and that mail-in
voting dana that you touched on
that's going to play a huge part well
actually emily on the nbc
poll that we're citing here it reflects
the exact exit polling from 2016
plus four republican and that's why you
got a tied race